elena quiere construir un intervalo a
partir de una muestra con base en
puntaje z para estimar la proporción de
computadoras con algún tipo de defectos
que se producen en una fábrica ella
escoge un nivel de confianza del 95% en
una muestra aleatoria de 200
computadoras encuentra que 12 tienen
algún defecto cuál es el valor crítico z
estrella que elena debe usar para
construir su intervalo de confianza así
que antes de que te pida que pausa es el
vídeo recordemos que es un valor crítico
recuerda la idea detrás de los
intervalos de confianza es estimar un
cierto parámetro el cual en este caso es
la proporción de la población de
computadoras que cumple con una cierta
característica que en este caso es tener
algún defecto
así que tenemos una cierta proporción
poblacional la cual desconocemos pero
trataremos de estimar para eso tomamos
una muestra que en este caso es una
muestra aleatoria de 200 computadoras y
estimamos esto vamos a calcular la
proporción de la muestra que presenta
algún defecto ahora también queremos
construir un intervalo de confianza y
recuerda un intervalo de confianza con
un nivel de confianza del 95% significa
que si repetimos este proceso durante
varias veces seguimos construyendo estos
intervalos de confianza alrededor de los
estadísticos supongamos que este es uno
y este es su intervalo de confianza
asociado y después hacemos otra muestra
y encontramos aquí a este estadístico
pedos y también a su respectivo
a los de confianza bueno lo que me dice
este nivel de confianza del 95 por
ciento de estos intervalos es que
incluirán al verdadero parámetro de la
población aproximadamente en el 94 por
ciento de los casos y la forma en la que
lo haremos es tomar el estadístico
déjame expresar esto de manera general y
se aplicaría no solamente para la
proporción en el futuro podríamos estar
interesados en estimar la media de la
población o lo que sea así que
calculamos nuestro estadístico déjame
escribirlo y después nos vamos a tomar
más menos
más o menos alrededor del estadístico
para considerar cuántas desviaciones
estándar de la distribución muestral
queremos tener alrededor de nuestro
estadístico y justo el número de
desviaciones estándar es el valor
crítico hace está estrella entonces va a
ser más o menos z estrella que va a
multiplicar a la desviación estándar del
estadístico
y ya está ahora en este caso particular
el estadístico que estamos usando es de
sombrero para esta muestra que elena
tomo que es la proporción muestral que
ella calculó y es lo que vamos a pensar
y ya esto le tendríamos que sumar y
restar entonces más o menos se te
estrella que es justo lo que nosotros
queremos z estrella que va a multiplicar
a la verdadera desviación estándar de la
distribución muestral de proporciones
pero necesitamos el parámetro de la
población que es algo que no tenemos
para saber cuál es su desviación
estándar por lo tanto lo que vamos a
hacer es multiplicar esta seta estrella
por el error estándar del estadístico
el error estándar
del estadístico y es lo que hemos hecho
en vídeos anteriores así que la clave en
este vídeo es encontrar hace está
estrella entonces supongamos que la
distribución muestra 'la que tenemos es
aproximadamente una distribución normal
y que esta es la media la cual es el
verdadero parámetro de la población un
que no sabemos pero lo que vamos a
buscar es cuántas desviaciones estándar
antes y después de la media necesitamos
para obtener un 94 por ciento de
probabilidad 94 por ciento del área
entonces y aquí tenemos el 94 por ciento
esta distancia
este número de desviaciones estándar va
a ser z estrella y esencialmente lo que
necesitamos hacer es observar la tabla
zeta pero hay que ser cuidadosos de que
tabla se está usaremos o si estamos
usando una función de una calculadora
hay que ser cuidadosos de que
es lo que hace la función precisamente
porque casi todas las tablas zetas hacen
lo siguiente para una seta tada nos
dicen cuál es el área total que va de
menos infinito hasta z desviaciones
estándar después de la media por lo
tanto una forma de pensar en esto es que
queremos encontrar la seta estrella que
deje no un 6% del área sin sombrear más
bien un 3% del área sin sombrear y de
donde obtuve un 3% bueno un 100 por
ciento menos 94 por ciento es 6 por
ciento pues recuerda que esto será
simétrico de ambos lados por lo tanto si
quieres un 3% sin sombrear por aquí y
otro 3% por acá entonces lo que
buscaremos en la tradicional tabla setup
que tiene el área acumulada será una
setup que nos deje un 3% sin sombrear de
este lado lo que significa una seta que
nos den una área acumulada del 90
7 % no de un 94% porque se encuentra una
seta que calcula en un 97% entonces
tendré también un 3% por aquí y por lo
tanto encontraremos el área que buscamos
de un 94% así que vamos a buscar la que
z nos da un área del 97% aquí tengo mi
tabla zeta
que es la misma que usó en los exámenes
de estadística de apem y si nos fijamos
en donde obtenemos un 97% que como
puedes ver es justo aquí este es el
número más cercano está acá es 6
diezmilésimos arriba de 0.97 y éste es
sólo un 10.000 simón abajo de 0.97 así
que este es el más cercano y si vemos
primero la fila es de 1.8 y nuestra
columna es de 0.08 entonces z es igual a
1.88 así que si nos regresamos a nuestra
pantalla original
ya sabemos que está z de aquí que
nosotros buscábamos es de 1.88 es decir
es la zeta que nos dan esta área que
sombrean un 97%
así que si vamos acá arriba 1.88
desviaciones estándar después de la
media y 1.88 desviaciones estándar antes
de la media eso dejarán un 3% de cada
lado de esta gráfica y por lo tanto
tenemos un área sombreada del 94% y ya
está la respuesta a la pregunta cuál es
el valor crítico z estrella que elena
debe usar para construir su intervalo de
confianza es decir esta z estrella que
tenemos aquí bueno ya sabemos que tiene
que tomar un valor de 1.88 y lo hemos
logrado hasta el siguiente vídeo